I got to take something up with you mhm
so every once in a while I get a message
from my agent mhm you know about this
that that that Paul gam needs to speak
to you and I go and I go yeah and I I
know you have my number but I go yeah
what's going on he goes I don't know
what it's about but Paul Gatti want to
speak to you it was the it was this book
your last book when you were on when you
were touring around talking about it I
just wanted to tell you how great I
thought it was that's all oh thanks but
even recently I got this message again I
get it every once in a while that Paul G
want to speak to me and I call you I get
your number uh I don't think I'm getting
I don't think I'm getting your calls so
maybe I'm being goofed on maybe
somebody's maybe you're really not
looking for me no cuz I think I've done
it maybe once and it was this and it was
about this mean you think somebody is
like yeah may be scamming me or
something saying they I don't know
somebody apparently just did do a scammy
thing with the with the AI voice thing
of me apparently scam scamming people me
of all people like why me who the hell
what is anybody going to fall for with
me but apparently they were doing that
with some AI voice thing but I don't
know if that's happening to you but I
don't know that that is me it's not this
is the only time I think I did it was
about that there's this thing around you
that Sher is a huge fan of yours and she
wants to speak to you and speak with you
she does that to me I every now and then
I get a I get a message from somebody
that says share not just she really
needs to talk to me like it's important
like crucial that she talks to me and
I'm like what the [__] why does sheer
want to talk to me nobody will tell me
and then I never hear anything then a
year will go by and then it happens
again that's what's happening to me with
you well it's not me it's got to be
somebody else eventually I did somebody
did because I do this podcast and and
somebody from the podcast did get in
touch with her and she did call me and
leave a message on my phone yeah and
then I all she said was hear you want to
talk to me that was it that was all she
said no you want to talk to me I was and
that's what I said I left her a message
and I said I thought you that's great
I'd love to talk to you but I thought
you wanted to talk to me and that's the
last I heard I haven't heard anything
again it's so weird I wonder what the
[__] she wants to talk about I have no
[__] idea I don't know what she could
possibly want to talk to me about and
it's like it's killing me I'm dying to
know what she wants to talk to me about
I mean it would be great I'd love to
talk to her about anything I don't care
it' be
fantastic